[Music]
last time I think you were on the show
you were here by yourself and you showed
a clip of you singing the national
anthem which was quite good and you also
of course got a lot of notoriety for
being in pitch perfect which leads one
to wonder is is there gonna be a musical
a MIDI a musical version of workaholics
I pitch perfect we're here I pretty sure
we're here for workaholics all respect
Conan but you know if you didn't want us
here then you know don't ask us
questions Bastion are you going in on
Conan when he asked us on his show and
then you go it on him because he's not
talking about our show it's not you
don't want me here tonight I won't be
here I want to EXCI I'm gonna I want to
talk to you dude
put on your words and I'm going out of
here like a sign or something Conan I
can't find my way out guys
I'm really sorry like they fight all the
time like they think of the best I'm the
best and like yeah I know there's a way
to get it back together again I think
what yeah here we go let's do this Jimmy
help me out
[Music]
[Music]
looking out the window
[Applause]
waiting for my best friend but he's no
well I can't wait until I can't see you
I'll pick up some steaks we can have a
barbecue me and you shall be bouncing to
the end cuz y'all
[Music]
out the window cause I just think about
you and it makes me wanna cry yeah
I miss you so much since you've been
away other people start to think that I
might be gay but I think that you are
really cool dude and sometimes at night
I see you in the stars
you're my best friend you're my best
friend
yo my background
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the caste award the Horlicks ladies and
gentlemen